Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to talk about the
incredible things NVIDIA showcased at
their recent keynote at SIGGRAPH, the world’s
premier computer graphics conference. Now, I am
a computer graphics researcher by trade, I work
in light transport simulations, in other words,
ray tracing, so many of the things that you
will see here today makes me very, very happy.
For instance, this is a showcase of what
their Omniverse system can do now. This
tool is for building virtual worlds. It can
do a lot, from storing volumetric effects,
to simulating them, to animating
robot hands, materials, animation,
high-quality geometry and hair simulations
too. The incredible scenes that you see
here were built by USD composer, this is an
Omniverse app to build large-scale scenes.
And now, hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because some of these virtual worlds are becoming
incredibly convincing. Now what does that even
mean? Well, I talked about simulations that are
almost indistinguishable from reality in a little
paper not so long ago, yes, what you see here is
a computer simulation. Not reality. The link to
the paper is available in the video description.
So, today we ask, can scientists at NVIDIA
perform something similar? How
good are their virtual worlds?
So let’s see what they have here. Number
one, OpenUSD. USD stands for universal scene
descriptor, and this supports creating virtual
worlds in way such that visual effects people,
designers, engineers and roboticists can work
together easily. For instance, this is a virtual
car that is almost the same as the real car
it represents and it is assembled from the
smallest individual parts. Then, artists can
see what the car would look like in reality,
create new variants of it, create a gorgeous
backdrop where they would showcase this car,
try different environments, and it is
even possible to take it for a ride.
And what really blows my mind is
not only that all this is possible,
but that all this is possible today in real time.
Everything runs as we are looking at it. Wow.
Number two, now, if this system can
create really detailed geometry,
that is great. However, not everyone is a CAD
designer, not everyone can model, or understand
materials as a physicist does, but everyone can
speak English. So, they have this new interface
where all we need to know is English,
and thus, we can now get a 3D floorplan,
generate lighting through the free and
open-source Blender, and through Adobe
Firefly integration, we can get floor textures
by just typing. I feel like we are going towards
a future where English is going to be the
interface of almost everything. You won’t
need to be an expert at everything, you will
have an expert AI assistant at your fingertips
with a ton of knowledge and infinite patience
ready to work for you. How amazing is that?
And you can simulate not only how things
look, but how things work too. Incredible.
Number three, they also showed us something that
they call Workbench. This enables fine-tuning
already existing AI models by giving
them additional knowledge. For instance,
with a text to image model, if we are asking
for a Toy Jensen in outer space, we get this.
Wait a minute…that’s not the Jensen we
are looking for is it? Now, of course,
this is because this model has never heard
of Jensen before, so we can teach it about
him using these 8 images, then ask again,
and…bam! There we go! Into outer space we go!
Of course, they have also showcased
shiny new hardware. Well, mostly shiny.
And finally, my favorite. If I hadn’t seen
anything else, just this one thing you are
seeing here, that would have been enough for me
to create a video about this keynote. This is a
video honoring some of the incredible works in
computer graphics, back from the olden times,
with the incredible animated human hand back
from 1972 from the legendary Ed Catmull,
co-founder of Pixar, and the first ray tracing
program from Turner Whitted from 1979. Imagine
simulating refractions on a computer more than 40
years ago. Wow. And up to what we are capable of
today. I am so happy to be able to share all
this with you, and just imagine what we will
be capable of just two more papers down the
line. My goodness. What a time to be alive!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!